hey sup guys my name is Hoshino and
welcome to the third episode of the
Sparky Engine series in which we're
making beautiful game engine from
scratch in C++ so today we'll be talking
attacking a look at our wonderful input
and specifically input from keyboard and
mouse and by mouse I mean buttons and
position as well on the screen so right
now or last time when we when we were
making this engine we left off with this
rectangle and it was nice and well we
had that actually from episode 1 but
what we did do was we loaded glue and we
verify that it works by doing cool stuff
like generating vertex rays and and
whatnot so that in mind it's time to
begin input so what I'm going to do is
under source I'm going to create a new
folder called input and it's in my
graphics well there no it's not good ok
let's get rid of graphics for now and in
there I'm going to put in a header file
I'm probably going to call this let's
see probably input one thing I'll be
referring to by the way and I recommend
that you guys do read if you're new to
input in GL FW is this GL f lobby input
guide so we'll be basing out everything
off this so it's a probably a good idea
to read this before we actually write
any code so basically we know that we
need to pull Avance
and that's really it and then what
happens is we set key callbacks based on
the window so what I actually might do
is put all this code into the window and
as you can see once we press ok we have
the power to activate an airship which
we will certainly be doing but all the
key callbacks will probably have to be
static functions and that's probably
about it so yeah it looks pretty
straightforward
this shouldn't be a very long episode
and I'm actually not gonna make that so
you know what in portfolio we died
I'll keep the forefather around perhaps
because Java B does support stuff like
joystick input so we'll probably be able
to connect controllers such as Xbox 360
controllers so
we can actually use them in our games
and I'll definitely put that in there
it's probably not the highest priority
thing to put in so I'm not gonna cover
that today but perhaps in the future so
anyway back in window according to this
we need to pull events I believe we're
already doing that yeah she'll have
totally Paulo Vance that's happening so
that's taken care of so all we need to
do now is set up callbacks and that's it
so what is a callback let's begin with
that essentially a callback is pretty
much a function pointer so what happens
is we tell GL FW here is a pointer to a
function I want you to call this
function whenever you want okay and then
GL of W will be like was a keep was a
key pressed on our keyboard and if the
answers yes or in fact if any cave-in
happens doesn't matter if it's press or
a release gel Adobe has that function
pointer and it will call the function
and be like I'm calling it and then of
course the function is something we give
it so we make the function so whatever
code we put in there will just work so
you guys are familiar with Java is
basically like making an interface with
a methods such as run or something or
invoke write and then of course it will
invoke that method when it wants which
is in this case when a kid gets pressed
so that being said the other thing
that's really important to know is that
these callbacks they have to be they
cannot be normal methods in a class they
have to be either functions they have to
be either functions or they can be
static methods okay you can't have an
instance and be like I want a callback
for this instance okay it's just it's
not something you can do I'm pretty sure
maybe there's a way around that but
there's no standard way to do that so
that being said we're probably going to
we're probably just going to make
standard functions I think or yep so
we've got a few considerations to to
play with I probably will actually make
static methods for it so the first thing
we'll need is a static boolean array
I'll call something like keys so our
idea is
let me just map this out for you guys
real quick and I do have a turkey on the
stove by the way so I'm going to try and
make this quick but that being said and
of course you guys can wondering what
I'm talking about having a turkey on the
stove but that's why you should have
watched the livestream anyway so we want
keys right so what's going to happen is
this window glass is going to have a
boolean array and this boolean array
will be called something like keys and
it will be set to a lot a large number
that will cover most of the keys on our
keyboard let's just say what happens is
when a key gets pressed we get something
called a key code in this case G lfw
actually has two variables there's one
called a scan code which is not really
what we want and there's one called a
key which is what we want so it gives us
essentially a key code so it's a numeric
representation of the key it's not
simply the character converted into an
integer it's not that it's a represented
representation of a specific key on the
keyboard so let's just say we press
something like the a key and it gives us
50 okay if it gives us 50 we can be like
let's use this integer as an index in
this array so we use it as an index and
to do that we just call keys then the
actual key code right or in this case 50
which will be the key code right and we
set it equal to true when it gets
pressed now when the key gets released
we simply take the same thing here and
we set it equal to false okay and that
is it that is the whole story okay so we
use the key code as as an index in our
array we do the exact same thing with
the mouse buttons and then of course
with the mouse position on the window we
can simply use an X Y okay and I believe
a GL of W gives us a double for that so
we'll probably use doubles that's it
that's the whole story it's pretty
amazing so
that being said we should probably start
implementing this the only thing I
wanted to mention was there I don't
think so no okay let's begin if anything
I'll go back to the drawing board on ure
so we need to make these static let's we
need to make these static because again
we have to use functions and not and not
methods and the other the other thing is
we might as well make them static
because let's be honest we're only going
to have one kind of keyboard registered
to one window at a time so it's not like
we'll be focused in on multiple windows
at once or something so the first thing
we need to do is let's just make this so
I'll make it 1024 in fact we might even
define we might even define something
such as max keys for now and we'll set
it equal to 1024 just in case we do want
to change that later and we'll similarly
make one so I'll call this these are
private so I'll call these using our
convention of course so M keys and M
buttons so buttons will be mouse buttons
so I'll probably call this mouse buttons
and then define max buttons will be
something like 32 probably and I'll
probably align these to make them nice
is that nice maybe not maybe I'll just
do that um so we've got max keys and max
buttons okay fantastic so now these
arrays have been created I also want to
make a static double MMX wala just looks
hilarious so a mouse X and mouse Y so
I'll probably just call these MX and my
let's go back to this real quick the
mouse movement will be handled with
something weight is killed abusing
support image loading doesn't because
that would be spectacular anyway that's
another episode mouse give me mass
position guys a position so yes so it
gives you a double X position in a
double y position so yeah well we'll
have them as doubles okay cool
so let's begin with key input first I'm
going to make a private static function
here so they'll be a static let's take a
look at what it wants you wants this is
what it wants right this is the function
prototype that it wants so let's take
this let's paste it in here I'll call
this I'll just probably leave this as
Kate call back and I'll probably leave
everything else as its because it's
pretty much that's pretty much all we
want okay let's implement that for now
so back in window I'm gonna make void so
we had window resize uh actually no
window resize wasn't part of this was it
oh this is annoying okay so we have to
decide probably what we want to do it
because there's no point making a bunch
of static private methods if we've got
just window resize chillin here well
okay I guess we won't then
so we'll keep this stuff here but we
will make the methods as just standard
functions there won't be part of this
class at all okay okay just because the
we didn't for the resize apparently so
where was resize this was the prototype
and then they kept I'm assuming it got
cold somewhat yes so set window races
ahead window size callback okay so
there's our key callback so I'll
probably I'll probably just change the
callbacks to all be on the school so any
see any standard C function C style kind
of procedural function will be in this
convention and then methods will be in
the convention with the terminal it's
called camelcase or come in kill me case
is what's called like that okay so um so
can we just update that to be true
window resize and then we'll declare I
don't really I could just implement it
up here but I'm not going to okay cuz I
don't want it bro
alright so again what we need to do is
we need to get the current window it
gives us a gel FW window not a current
window so what we need to do is somehow
get the current window that is being
used and set its key or set its you know
relevant key in the boolean array to
true okay if the key is pressed so to do
that we need to probably have some way
to have a static kind of instance of the
window because we can't simply be like
long this dot key or something or what
is it m keys and index we can't do that
because we'd have no idea what the
current instance of this window is as
you can see we're not in window anymore
we're in just global function space well
we're not global functions based on its
bar key traffic spot we're not inside
the window so how do we do that well
what we could do is we could make a
private or a public and we'll probably
just make this public
well maybe we'll make a public window
okay we'll call it instance this would
be a pointer to a window
well probable we'll actually have a
constant if we have a concept we mean we
have to initialize it okay well just
make a static window instance just like
that okay and then what I'm going to do
is when any window gets created the
current instance will change to be this
alright in the future we should probably
make it so that we can change we
probably could change it to something
else in the future but you know for now
this will work okay so once we've got a
instance and whatnot we can go ahead and
say window instance right and then we
can access stuff like we probably won't
be able to because that's not public law
all right so there is actually another
way to do this
it seems again so all input callbacks
receive a window handle by using the
window use a pointer you can access non
global structures or objects from your
callbacks okay so we can use something
such as GLW set window user pointer or
get window use a pointer to be able to
actually access our window class okay
so let's check it let's take a look at
how we can use this function sets the
user-defined pointer of the specified
window all right cool so it takes in a
window okay cool so when we create okay
so I'm sorry to be all over the place
but I don't want to remind you that this
series isn't it's it's basically me
making a game engine from scratch all in
front of you so of course referring to
documentation is something that we will
do from time sign so what we do is when
we make the window which is right over
here and we set a lot of callbacks we
call gfw set window user pointer okay we
pass in the current window which is the
jail of w window which is called m
window yeah and then we pass in this as
the pointer okay then what we do is well
over here we receive this window object
so we can call GL fw get user window
well well well get window user pointer
my goodness and then we have just just
passed in the window that will force
return a void pointer which we can
basically get into our windows so we
need to cast this it's a window window
well I call this wind because there's
all windows already taken will be equal
to the window that okay so we can use
that instead and that is much better
than having to do what i which is
proposing to do okay so we simply set
the user pointer to this of course and
basically but basically all we're doing
is we're giving this window object that
we created GL at Bobby's window a memory
address of this current window class so
that we can then change stuff okay and
then we can call something like when
problem is we're not going to have
access to public to private methods so
what we could do is another little cool
trick so this is turning out to be quite
the episode I didn't think this would be
this complicated but it looks like we're
making this this complicated so jail of
w window is a class currently it was
struct actually it's a struct that um
which makes no difference by the way but
it's a struct that
is it obviously a different struct to
our window object so we obviously cannot
go ahead and say when dots and keys
because mkz's private and we can only
access public things there is a way
around that what we can do is we can
mark gfw window as a friend okay if we
mark it as a friend it means that GLW
window is our friend and we are letting
gfw window access our private stash of
data okay so to mark something as a
friend you can simply tie and this can
be anywhere you can do this here for
example and I think because it's a
struct I'll have to type in friend
struct instead of for in a class
whatever but you just go friend struct
GL of W window okay and once you do
something like this you can go back here
and you can see that wall so we can't do
that but what we can do is a static
callbacks oh so this is where it gets
even more complicated this is going to
be the worst episode in the history
these callbacks have to be marked as
friends additionally to everything else
oh great great
let's go back here for one second
because I think this mentioned something
about private members this is going to
be this is going to be the most
complicated input you loved up the input
tutorial in the history but I don't I'm
not even mad about that let's go back
here not like yeah yeah yeah and that's
not useful at all okay
all right so back to the drawing board
so we're going to go back here and make
this a static and we'll make this a
friend okay
so this is now a friend static forward
key callback we keep the implementation
here as usual in fact if we go up here
we can just get rid of this and if I go
down here this should now hopefully yes
link to this so it's that and now thank
you
so now we have access to all of this
okay so that's and don't worry about the
turkey by the way guys sorry I'm talking
to the stream right now for those of you
watching this video this is gonna be the
worst video in the series let's focus
the turkeys fine okay now let's set em
keys at key equal to true now this of
course is something that only happens if
the window it gets pressed so how do I
sorry if the key gets pressed okay if
you get if it gets released we need to
set it equal to false now unfortunately
this is further complicated by the fact
that there are two different press
methods there's a press and there's like
a repeat a repeat happens when a key has
been pressed and begins being pressed
again so in other words you know if you
hold a key down you know it registers
one press and then it registers a bunch
of prices so that presses is the second
part of this so what we can do is when
we do set our key callback which is this
is in window okay
there's Jill if W press so action is
what we want right so essentially right
action can eat can equal many things
such as jill fw press then there's also
g lfw repeat yeah and then there's
release so essentially what we want to
do is we want to say if action doesn't
equal jail w release so if this is true
then essentially our keys pressed right
because only if jail fw release is
activated is our key false so if we grab
this we can simply put it into here and
well and this should work okay so we
also need to instantiate this array or
rather rather initialize this array so
as well as actually set other properties
while here which we'll cover in a minute
but for in equals zero is less than our
max keys I'm plus plus we'll set case I
equal to and it's actually M keys I
equal to false fantastic so and we'll do
the same thing for them mouse buttons
alright good so everything's false by
default of course and then it gets
pressed finally we should have some kind
of way to check the current key if it's
being pressed right so probably just mmm
we could do a bunch of things with that
I think I might as well make it static
so we'll make a static bull is key
pressed maybe I'll call it key press I
don't know int key card right and then
I'll grab that we'll go back here and
let's just put it over here so we'll get
rid of the static of course we don't
need that it's already static I'll put
it into our window namespace thing it
all we'll do is we'll return keys at or
other M keys at key code so we should
probably do something like check to make
sure the key code is in range so I'll
put that as a to do we won't bother with
that for now you know what we might as
well if key code we'll make it an
unsigned int so if key code is greater
than or equal to max keys then we're
outside of the range so we'll just
return false and which probably logs
something so once we have a logging
system will love something
we'll make a logging system eventually
as well but well log this as being an
error okay cool so back to here we need
to make sure that this is unsigned all
right this will also be yeah that's
pretty much it right we can Markus Const
as well I know we can't yeah we can't
cuz it's static obviously I forgot I
made a static so the reason I made it
static is because all this stuff is
static right sometimes I wouldn't do
that but in this case I don't see I
don't really think there's a need to
have multiple windows at once so for now
we'll we'll continue on with this static
schpeel but eventually I don't know
everything should be fine this should
work okay cool now that's done we should
test this out so back in Maine oh one
thing I forgot to mention by the way is
these static things actually have to be
implemented in the CPP file so if we
take this for example M keys right at
the top here
well anywhere really we need to
basically declare this as being a thing
okay and specifically we need to give it
an initialization so max keys right
there we go
and we have to do the same thing for the
buttons so mouse buttons max buttons
okay cool
and we have to do that for every static
member so this is the MX and my are also
static of course so we have to do that
as well so this syntax for this is
obviously just return type and then
window and then that we don't have to
give it any value by the way and then
the same thing for my and there we go
fantastic so now that this is all set up
we shouldn't get any errors let's try
and build this good so now in here let's
type in something like
esidisi our window dots is key pressed
gfw key a something yeah
so if we run this now zero and then if I
press a on my keyboard while I'm
pressing it and I'm not getting a result
fantastic let's quickly put this into a
gif block as well so if we know keep
probably well we will set that and we'll
print out something like pressed all
right so it's not being press right now
let's double check that though okay so
it's not being pressed let's go back and
investigate what's wrong
so kikyo it is so make sure let's just
make sure this isn't happening
65 yeah that's fine and then we forgot
to set the call back okay so that was
silly um let's go back here and then
there's this window size call back let's
make sure that we set a is it just
capable back set key call back okay
and window and then key call back all
right done so if we run this now and we
press the letter A hopefully you'll see
the words pressed here okay fantastic so
keyboard is working let's cover mouse
mouse is going to be largely the same
the same deal alright we've got is key
pressed is button pressed or is mouse
button pressed on signed into button
well whoa
yes so you can have multiple windows
that will be supported but basically
you'll have to have an instance for them
so we'll talk about that later yeah we
could have made multiple windows we'll
deal with that as more of an advanced
feature in the window sorry I'm by the
way for those of you who are watching
this not live I was just answering a
chat question in the twitch.tv chat okay
so we've got this let's quickly set a
mouse button callback right which will
be our mouse button pull back so there's
a keyhole back we'll make a mouse button
callback let's go and let's find mouse
input so that's yeah yeah where are my
buttons here we go so many miles minutes
I said yes
so it's just that
all right so now that we've got our
fantastic mouse button callback let's go
over here and actually implement it okay
so um let's get our window and then
we'll say when M mouse buttons at index
button Eagles now what actions do we
have available to us is it the same
thing just press is there even a jail if
W repeat okay I guess I'll just do the
same thing for there we go well done
alright so there's our mouse buttons
let's check this out
what do we have jobs mouse button right
for example so is all I haven't planted
the mouse button thing so let's copy and
paste the the keys
so we'll go if mouse button pressed
Mouse rather button what we call it max
buttons and then will return will return
and mouse buttons and the button all
right fantastic so that looks pretty
good
let's just grab this cuz I need to make
sure that it's in my prototype I was
well I already wrote it okay so there we
go
that should work let me just double
check yep so back in Maine we'll use
something like is mouse button pressed
glf W Mouse Boston one let's actually
probably use mouse button right or
something on left so mouth on the left
and then if I click hopefully as you can
see
it is registering as breasts fantastic
so that is done now the last thing we
have is positioning of the mouse on the
screen so we can do that using and will
do stuff like cursor leave events and
one on in the future as well but because
of position we simply have a cursor
position callback it's exactly the same
so this is the cursor position callback
let's grab that let's put it into here
let's difficult let's declare it as a
friend we'll keep everything else as is
we've got our Y position in our
exposition and then all we have to
really do is let's see we have to make a
so what's the callback set occurs a
position call back set there's a
position callback so I should probably
call this Y as a physician call back
okay and then finally to implement it
let's grab our okay as a position call
back
let's grab this our window let's go
ahead and set the windows yeah so the
other thing I want to mention is that
these no longer have to be static since
we're using this so let's set this MX
equal to X position and then let's set
my equal to Y position okay good so
that's basically all we have to do so
now in main now in window if we had
something along the lines of static bull
mouse or get mouse position and just I
think for now we'll just take in so
we'll go so this will return a vac to
eventually like a two component vector
but since we don't have that for now
we'll simply take in double X and double
Y by reference of course and then will
spit out loci well yeah we'll just set
them and that's it so where's our stuff
okay so window that and then we'll just
set X equal to MX and y put my okay
that's really all we have to do so now
let's see this in action we will print
out so we'll quickly make a double X Y
will go window dot guess the mouse
position X Y okay and it will print out
X
why ok so now we should see relative to
the window as you can see where our
mouse is on the screen fantastic so now
let's quickly clean this up one thing
that I should note is that making this
static is totally an option we don't
actually have to make it static what we
could do instead is make it non static
so right now we have the ability to call
this by simply going window get Mouse
position no matter where we are okay we
don't have to have an instance of the
object that could be nice because if
we're in some other class we don't want
to be passing around the instance it's
just an unnecessary variable for us
because there is really only one window
anyway however if people do want to use
it it could become a problem so we might
have something like window instance and
then get mouse position if you really
want to use it like that and that would
mean that this would be static
this would not okay because we don't
need it to be static so I'm going to
wipe out the static Ness and make it not
static I think so I'll grab the static
by the way a quick shortcut if you hold
down alt while selecting text you can
kind of select text download like this
it's really useful so if I just hit
delete on that and you can see I'm
typing in like the entire thing I'm
gonna make that not static these will
still be static all right
they have to be and we'll make all this
stuff not static as well all right there
we go so now that everything is not
static we have to go back into window
and remove all of this okay but on the
bright side if we run this now you can
see it still runs and we're not static
anymore okay pretty cool stuff
so now that we're non-static let's go
ahead and apply the correct amount of
constants to everything so he's key
pressed will put constant at the back of
everything meaning it can't actually
modify anything because these are
basically getters and they shouldn't be
doing that anyway so let's put that
there and of course that'll be
functionally useful when we decide to
pass in a window as a Const reference
for example so now we're on this there
you go all right there is all of the
input you could dream of we've got Mouse
position
mouse buttons and keys okay fantastic so
that's gonna wrap up this episode of
this Bakke series if you guys enjoyed
the episode please don't forget to hit
the like button and I will see you guys
tomorrow when we're going to cover maths
okay so that's gonna be stuff like
vectors and matrices awesome
all right I'll see you guys then good
bye